BORIS FARBER: Thanks, Bill.
Thanks, everyone, for coming
over and keeping up with us
in this time.
My name is Boris.
I'm part of a partner
engineering team, which
is essentially, please look
at us as your Google partners
to success.
I want to forward
the mic to Guy,
who is one of our top partners,
to describe the awesome system
they designed,
using various APIs,
to support an enormously
increasing number of devices.
GUY ULMER: Right.
So Boris is very humble,
but we did build this thing
on the shoulders of giants,
in this specific case, Google,
but I'll also talk about some
other publicly available data
that we used.
Just a little bit about us.
We're a fairly large studio,
with over 1,200 people
across eight different
offices around the world.
It's not just boasting PR here.
When you have so many
studios and they mostly
work independently, the
same kind of questions
usually pop up.
One studio already
solved that problem,
and then another studio
is tackling it again,
which is basically
why I joined Plarium
two and a half years ago.
My title is platform
technology specialist,
but essentially what
it means is that I'm
serving as some
kind of interface
between the internal studios
and the platform holders.
And what I try to do at
Plarium is drive innovation
through adoption
of new technology.
So think of me as an internal
evangelist of new tech
if, for example, Google comes up
with a Google Play integration
into Chrome OS devices,
that's something
that I would try
to push internally,
look for the right studio in the
right time in their pipeline,
to kind of integrate that tool.
I'm also doing research.
So I'll let the R&D
guys deal with the team,
with the development.
I'm part of the research
team, but while the rest
of the research team is actually
doing market research, which
means they are playing games,
I'm doing technology research.
And my background is actually
in the EDA, or Electronic Design
Automation industry.
I used to work at
Cadence Design System.
I think they're headquartered
somewhere over there,
but I'm a bit disoriented now.
And when I joined Plarium, the
first question I had to tackle
is the fact that there are
over 15,000 devices registered.
And when you go to
Google Play Dashboard,
you will see that number.
Other resources track even
higher number of devices,
but it's still in the
thousands, or tens of thousands.
So developers approached
me, and they told me,
hey, our biggest problem is that
we don't know which devices we
should target if we want
to optimize the process,
and which devices
should we test on.
So that was basically my
first research project
at the company, and it's
an ongoing research,
because that market
changes all the time.
And you need the
right tools, right?
You want to navigate
an ocean, you're
not going to take that
old crumbling ship.
Technically that's not an ocean.
That's the Mediterranean,
but I still
didn't have time to
take any pictures here
in San Francisco, in the Bay
Area, of an actual ocean.
So that's all I had.
So there are many ways to
measure this kind of data.
You can use internal data
if your company is already
established.
You have some games
in the market,
you can poll the devices
that your players are using.
But there are two
problems there.
First of all, you have
to make sure you actually
collect the data, and
the right kind of data.
There is a lot of misreporting
when it comes to these devices,
and you have to do
some manual tweaking.
And it also means
that you're skewed
towards your
current player base.
So if for example our bread and
butter is MMO strategy games,
and suddenly we want to
design an action RPG game,
it might not be
the same user base
that play this kind of games.
They might actually have
different device properties, so
the data that we have
internally might not
be the best data for the job.
Luckily there is some
publicly available data,
or maybe there was
publicly available data.
OpenSignal reports-- they used
to share public information up
until 2015.
And then if anyone is familiar
with Unity Analytics hardware
starts, they used to have
a public page for that,
and I think that the
last time it was updated
was in March 2017.
So that's around a year ago.
No problem with that.
I think there's also
some initiative in Unity
for sharing this kind
of data with developers,
but you have to work with
them, and it's not something
that you can just
get off the web.
And then Google, they also
have their Android distribution
dashboards, but that
information is kind of limited.
But when you look
at all of that--
you have your internal data, you
have publicly available data,
you can actually kind of work
the two things together--
and then you realize that, hey,
the top 10 devices represent
just 15% of the market.
Again, this is from
the OpenSignal report,
so this data is,
like, three years old,
but while the devices
change, the fact
that the top 10
devices in Android
don't represent a large
portion of the market
is still an ongoing issue.
It's something that
still exists today.
I think that the number
is even smaller right now,
and ideally you want to
reach better coverage
than 15% of the market.
So you have to take
a different approach,
and this is what I did.
Again, I used to work
in the EDA industry.
I had a lot of relations with
the hardware manufacturers,
mostly in the mobile space.
So when you look at
all of these devices
there is actually some things
that are common to all of them.
All of them have the same
resolution, 4 gigs of RAM,
and even more
importantly, all of them
are running the same Snapdragon
820 chipset, and the Adreno 530
GPU.
Samsung is special in that
regard because their Galaxy S
devices, you can have two
different devices running
completely different SOCs
underneath, either their own
[INAUDIBLE] or Snapdragon.
I think there are some
other manufacturers
with that kind of division,
but Samsung is definitely
the largest one.
And all of these devices are
running-- or at least used
to run Android 6
when they released.
And that basically
means that maybe we
don't have to test for each
of these individual devices.
We can just take one of
them as a representative.
And so this is
basically the SOC,
or System On a Chip approach.
Android devices,
they're dominantly
ARM architecture-based,
98% of the market.
And eventually you
have only a handful
of hardware manufacturers, so
Qualcomm, Samsung, MediaTek,
Huawei, and some others
that are developing
these SOCs that are basically
in each and every Android phone.
So there's still you know
loads of combinatorics
that are going on.
So two SOCs-- one SOC
might be used on phones
that have different RAM
and OS configurations,
but that is still
much easier to track
than 15,000 separate devices.
So looking at it from
an SOC perspective,
the different component
of the system on a chip,
you can actually
tackle the market
by separating the
devices into buckets.
So looking at the
graphic GPU component,
we can see right here--
again, this is old data,
but 80% of the market
was dominated back then
by 10 different GPUs.
So it means that if I want to
test my game on different GPUs,
I don't have to test on
10 devices to get just 15%
of the market.
If I use the data wisely, I
can test 10 different models
and cover 80% of the GPU market.
Again, these are 2015 numbers.
It changes over time.
But the fact that
around 80% of the market
is covered by 10
to 15 devices, that
remains the same over time.
So again, you can pick up
different distinct devices,
and have a very good
QA coverage, which
brings us to the next question,
which device should I target?
I have let's say
10 different GPUs,
and what we usually try
to do is go for the lowest
common denominator.
The weakest GPU is the one that
we should target as our base,
and then we can say, hey,
if we target these eight,
we cover 80% of
the market, and its
likely that the other graphic
cards will be stronger
or more powerful than that.
And this is where you can
actually use benchmark websites
to the rescue.
GF expansion, 3D mark, basically
if you look at the benchmarks
there, you can see that looking
at these devices, Mali 400,
that was actually the most
popular device back in 2015.
It covered almost one
third of the market.
It was also the weakest
out of these eight.
So it was easy for me
to rely on these data,
and go back to our
developers and tell them,
hey, if you target the
Mali 400 as your base GPU,
you will easily cover
80% of the market,
and you won't have to worry
about other devices that
are too weak for
the game to run on.
And so that was
GPU segmentation.
There's also OS
market segmentation.
And again, that's
where Google really
helps us with their own
distribution dashboards.
It's a public website.
You can just Google it.
And if you're not familiar
with it already, you should be.
Again, you need to run
some sanity checks.
Do these overall Android numbers
represent your actual target
market, because you're
developing games,
and maybe that includes
Android watch devices
and stuff like that.
You want to try
and cross-reference
that with different
numbers, either your own
or some other external
source, to try
to see if that's the
ideal market that you're
looking into.
But then again, my game
will be released next year,
and not today.
And so I'll quote a
person of the year, Kane,
"he who controls the past
commands the future."
Anyone familiar
with that character,
or am I the only person who
played Command and Conquer?
OK, there are a few.
Great.
It didn't go unnoticed.
So what we can do
with that information,
Google basically gives
us the current snapshot.
But that's why we have an
internet Wayback Machine.
Just look at older
historical cached
snapshots of the same page,
and with some spreadsheet
manipulation skills, you can
actually try to plot the graph.
So back in March 2017, when
one of our studios told me,
hey, I'm going to target--
I'm going to release
the game only in 2018,
should I target Android 4.4,
I was able to go back to them
and tell them,
hey, it looks to me
that by 2018, it will cover
only 10% of the market,
and lower Android
releases will cover
even less than
that, so we're still
looking at 80% of the market
if you only target Android 5
and above.
So that's useful
information, not only
if you look at it right
now, but also if you
try to plan for the future.
Another sort of
fragmentation that we have
is screen size fragmentation.
It's still a problem,
because while I
did find some public
sources, there were
some issues with some of them.
Again, devices sometimes
misreport the screen size.
And then you have the official
numbers from the Android
dashboard, but in
Android dashboard,
they usually give you
the resolution in DPI,
and not the--
sorry, not resolution,
but the device sizes--
you know, different
category buckets,
like large, extra
large, and the DPI.
And sometimes what
you're looking into
is actual resolutions--
how many devices are
running on one ATP?
How many are running above that?
And there's also
aspect ratios, right?
Devices are getting
wider or taller
depending on the orientation.
And if you want to ask
yourself the question, hey,
should I support
18 by nine devices?
Should I support ultra-wide
21 by nine devices,
there is no way to
gather public data that
tells you how many
devices in the market
are actually in
that aspect ratio.
And that's even before getting
into display cutouts, which
is the trending thing since
the Essential phone, I think,
last summer.
But expect to see based on
the Barcelona conference--
Barcelona expo, you should
see a lot more of those
in the coming year or
years, and that will make
things even harder for you.
So I think that one of
the biggest things for us
was when Google released their
device catalog in the Play
Console.
It basically lets you see all
the supported Android devices,
and you can click on each device
and see detailed hardware info.
If you're not familiar with
that part of the console,
you should definitely
get yourself
familiar with that,
because it also
lets you, instead of working
with the manifest file,
you can actually work
directly from there,
and exclude your game by
blacklisting it on devices
that you don't want to support.
So for example, if you
found a serious OpenGL
bug that happens
on Nexus 9 device,
maybe you want to remove that
until you actually fix the bug.
So players won't download
your game on the Nexus 9,
and then get crashes and
give you bad reviews.
And what's even cooler is that
you can actually filter devices
based on the different specs.
So that works exactly in the
direction I mentioned earlier.
That's like the SOC approach.
And then I can raise
another question-- hey,
we found a serious
OpenGL bug in Nexus 9.
Maybe it's not
just with Nexus 9.
Maybe it's also with other
Tegra K1-based devices.
So the Nvidia Shield
tablet, for example,
is running the exact same SOC.
If you're blacklisting
Nexus 9, you
might want to consider
blacklisting similar devices
as well.
And now you can actually
get all that information
in a very easy way.
But that's not
all, because what's
even cooler is that it helps
us answer a different marketing
questions, right.
So if we have the
technical question coming
from one of the studios,
hey, should I support devices
with less than 1 gigabyte
of RAM in my game that
is already released,
because I'm starting,
you know, there is
a feature creep,
and I'm trying to
implement new stuff,
and suddenly I'm not so sure
that the older devices will
work with that feature set.
And so essentially the
marketing question they have is,
what percent of the
player base is even
running the game on devices with
less than 1 gigabyte of RAM?
And an even better
question would
be, hey, how is my game rated
on players that have devices
with less than 1
gigabyte of RAM,
because maybe there is a huge
percentage of them playing
the game on these devices, but
they're already having a really
bad experience,
and they're rating
your game in a negative way.
And essentially
what we really want
to know-- let's
be greedy, right--
what revenue percentage is
coming from devices with less
than 1 gigabyte of RAM?
And the Device Catalog
gives you answers
to all these questions, right.
In case you've never
seen it before--
OK, these are fake
numbers, right.
None of our games make $3
billion US a month yet.
But let's say, 30
million devices
with less than 1 gigabyte
of RAM represent only 13%
of your user base.
But at the same time, they
represent 2/3 of your revenue,
and they gave you
a very good rating.
So that's definitely-- I'd
go back to that developer
and I tell him, no, you
shouldn't drop support
for 1 gigabyte of RAM.
If anything you
should drop support
for everything else except
that, because of these numbers.
So if you haven't used
Device Catalog, either
for this purpose or
other purposes, that's
one of the most powerful
tools, I think, for us
on the Google Play console.
It's something that you should
be familiar with, and use it.
But then you also have
to remember a few things.
The first one is that
market changes over time.
So I talked about it earlier,
but if one of the developers
asked me the same
question, and they're only
developing a game that will
be released in late 2019,
these numbers will also change.
If 30% of the market right
now has less than 1 gigabyte
of RAM, I can expect that number
to be smaller as time goes by.
That's something to remember.
And you also have to remember
that this data is just
for your game.
The more games you
have the better,
because you can cross
reference, but it's
skewed towards the games that
your player base is playing.
If you're making
[INAUDIBLE] games,
and suddenly you want to make a
new Battle Royale game, that's
slightly different
markets, so maybe you
shouldn't be looking at the same
devices as the current player
base you have right now.
So all of these advices
were for development.
If you didn't listen
to that advice,
because why test before release,
and nobody got time for that,
there's another
tool, Android Vitals,
that help you track
potential issues in the wild,
after your game was
already released.
Again, it's a great
tool on its own.
Recently, for example, it helped
us track a rise of new issues
that happened in already
stable games that
were in maintenance mode.
So no new updates.
They're already
out in the market,
and suddenly there was an
uptick in the crash rate in one
of these games.
So that's a good indication,
even if nobody is actually
looking at the numbers for your
own internal crash analysis
tool.
If there's somebody
to look at the vitals,
then you've got
your bases covered.
But in the context
of device targeting,
we can use that and
the Device Catalog
together to actually
close the loop.
So for example, if I see
a specific crash, right--
an increase in crash.
I get bad behavior report
from Android Vitals,
I need to ask myself the
question, should I fix this,
or should I exclude devices
that have this kind of bug?
So again, this isn't
a recommendation
to test in
production, but if you
look at this specific example,
the Samsung Galaxy S8 suddenly
showed almost a quarter of
the sessions in that device
crashed, and older devices
didn't have any problems.
So that brings up
the question, hey,
is this problem unique
to some Galaxy S8,
or maybe it's
because it's running
a new version of
Android, or maybe it's
because it's a new SOC.
And if I use Android Vitals
and Device Catalog together,
I can actually try to narrow
the question down and find
what the actual
problem is, and then it
would be easier for me to
decide if I want to fix it
or if I want to exclude it.
So that's basically how we
already use some of the tools
that Google provides us with.
We'd obviously like to see more.
OK, so for anyone here from
Google, this is my wish list.
We want to see more filters
in the Device Catalog,
and the same applies to
Android Developer dashboards.
Again, the big difference is
that Device Catalog gives you
numbers based on the
game you already have.
Android Developer
dashboards are general,
for the whole ecosystem.
So you should
really rely on both.
So for example, I want to
see what subset of the market
is already capable
to run 64-bit games.
If Google just announced
recently that by 2019 you
must be compliant with
64-bit, that's great,
but maybe I don't want to
manage two different versions.
Maybe I want to drop 32-bit.
And if 64-bit is right now
just 20% of the market,
or if it's 80% of that
[INAUDIBLE] market,
I'll have to answer that
question in a different way.
We'd also love to see
resolution and aspect
ratios and historical data,
because otherwise I'll
have to keep going to the
internet Wayback Machine
to get older snapshots.
And then just before--
I didn't even mention
Firebase Test Lab,
which is another great tool.
It was mentioned
in a previous talk.
But then again,
what I'd love to see
there is some kind of
coverage-driven approach
for SOCs.
So if Google is
giving us the ability
to test on 150 device
config combinations,
I want to see what
I already covered.
I want to see that I
covered the Snapdragon A20.
I wanted to see that I covered
that Exynos chip so I don't
have to test on two devices
that are supposedly different,
but actually they have
the exact same internals.
And last but not
least, a store listing
experiments-- another part
of the Device Catalog.
It's something that is actually
being used more by our business
performance team.
But again, if you could
integrate Device Catalog
capabilities into that so
we'd be able to A/B test
on two different
device segments,
so one with a large
amount of RAM,
another with smaller
see if it works any differently,
that might give us new insight
that we don't have right now.
OK, while I'm here,
I would also love
to see language and local
support for A/B testing there.
It's not technical,
but it's something
that the [INAUDIBLE]
people at my company
told me that I
should be mentioning.
But that's basically
it from my side,
so thank you very
much for listening.